The Gorosei are immortal and incredibly powerful
rulers from the void century that have been
ruling the world together with Imu for the
last 800 years.
For one, we know that they haven't aged a
day since the incident of Ohara 20 years ago.
They are called the 5 elder stars even though
some of them are not old at all.
They clearly know everything about the true
history and what happened during the void
century, as we can see when Dr. Clover tries
to say the ancient kingdom's name.
And we know that they are the highest ranking
celestial dragons, the world nobles who never
leave the Red line.
So why exactly would they be covered in scars
and carry weapons?
If just one of them decided to go out on an
adventure, that might be an excuse, but all
of them?
The world government has existed for 800 years,
so there clearly never was any reason for
celestial dragons to fight themselves.
Heck, even against Rocks, the biggest threat
to the government we know of, Garp had to
team up with Roger to defeat him.
If the Gorosei were immortal however, they
could be the very kings who defeated the ancient
kingdom and formed the world government in
the first place.
They would have actively fought in the big
war itself and then kept control ever since.
That would also explain, why they look and
act completely normal, compared to the other
dumbed down and spoiled Celestial dragons,
who have probably only had children within
their small group of chosen ones.
Yes, I'm saying there might be some incest
problem going on here.
I mean look at this.
[]
All of them run around in their space suits,
shielding them from the air normal humans
breathe, while the Gorosei have normal cloths
and have no problem being in the same room
with Akainu or even Shanks.
And so all these pieces of evidence together
strongly suggest to me, that these five men
are the original celestial dragons that founded
the world government with the help of Imu.
Which would also help in keeping the secret
ruler of the world secret, since they would
have been the only 5 people who knew the truth
since the void century, with no need to pass
it all on every generation and risking exposure.
But how did they end up becoming immortal
in the first place?
How powerful are these five men actually to
casually dismiss someone like Akainu and be
in the same room as one of the Yonko without
guards?
And will the marines ultimately rebel against
them?
What's up, my name is Manu and even though
I might not look it, I'm actually very interested
in politics and history, learning about how
we get where we are today and how societies
thrive or fail under different political systems.
And I think in terms of One Piece it doesn't
get much more political than when talking
about the 5 elders, who run and govern the
entire planet.
In fact what I find absolutely fascinating,
is that if you only have a vague idea of what
One Piece is actually about, you'd probably
be absolutely taken aback just how much politics
is actually hidden under the classic layers
of a Shounen Manga.
Not only do we encounter different political
systems and structures with every new island
we visit, but as the story progresses we learn
more and more about the workings of a political
organisation that rules the entire world.
Which, now that I think about it, is actually
pretty hilarious, because usually Shounen
Manga are about stopping an evil force from
reaching world domination, while in One Piece
this has already happened centuries ago.
And so the world of one piece is actually
a true dystopia, where a small group of inbred
and cruel nobles living on top of the red
line hold most of the wealth, enslave and
kill people at will and brainwash the people
with propaganda and lies.
All while the people on the sea below live
in poverty and despair and also in fear of
a culture of pirates, that has formed form
these desperate conditions.
What I love so much about Eiichiro Oda, the
author of one piece, is how he managed to
hide this dark and complex political foundation
of his story under the mantel of the positive
and fun adventure Luffy and co are on.
So even if you're someone who isn't really
into the politics of a story, you still know
exactly what's going on without you even realizing
it.
And it also makes the story enjoyable for
a younger shounen audience, with the deeper
and darker parts still being clearly visible
for the adults.
To me that once again shows what a masterful
writer Oda-sensei truly is.
In a way, you could argue, that the fight
of the ancient kingdom vs what would later
become the world government was the classic
Shounen setting.
Luffy on the other hand is a hero that doesn't
just have to stop the bad guys from winning,
he has to change and liberate an entire planet,
that has been ruled and indoctrinated for
almost 1000 years.
Which makes things much more interesting,
because it's not enough to just beat the big
bad guy to keep everything the way it is.
Luffy as the hero, has to actually present
the world with a system that works better
than the current one.
And I'm very curious how people will react
to the ideal system Oda envisions for the
end of the story.
No matter what it is it's probably gonna be
controversial, similarly how we all kept wondering
what political system the end of game of thrones
would bring with it.
Will the world of One Piece have a king?
Complete anarchy?
A democracy?
This will have a big impact on all Luffy is
achieving right now.
So who are these five men that tule the world
with an iron fist.
Are they good or evil?
How powerful are they?
And if they truly are immortal, how?
And what would it mean for the story if they
came form the void century.
In case you need a refresher, the five elders,
or Gorosei, as they are called in Japanese,
are a council of the most highly ranked Celestial
Dragons with full control over the Marines,
the cipher pole agencies and even the seven
Warlords of the sea.
While we know neither their names nor their
power, we have seen them pulling the strings
behind almost everything happening in the
world, politically rivalled only by the influence
of the four emperors, that actually hold both
the necessary political and military power
to deny the world government and rule over
the new world.
Now quite recently, we have learned that the
Gorosei actually serve a mysterious figure
called Imu, who rules the world from the shadows.
However, while the elders obey his orders,
it very much seems like most of the time they
still have full authority over the governments
actions.
Now, as you can imagine, tyranically running
an entire planet as a shadow government can
be an increadibly tiring job.
If you have a similar problem to the gorosei,
dealing with stressful fleet admirals, removing
parts of history and preparing big cleanses,
I got just the thing for you to sweeten your
day.
This awesome mystery snackbocks, sent to me
by Bokksu, one of my favorite sponsors.
Bokksu is a monthly snack box subscription
service that delivers original assortments
of premium Japanese snacks and tea pairings,
directly from Japan to wherever you live.
What I really like about this, is that they
collaborate with traditional Japanese family
manufacturers that make these snacks and candies.
So you don't just get some random stuff you
can in any Japanese supermarket, but actual
local stuff.
So, this is a really great opportunity to
experience some authentic Japanese food.
If you want to try it out for yourself, go
get your own Bokksu snack box and get 10%
off your first order using my code & link
in the description below!
So first of all, why do I think that the Gorosei
are actually very powerful and will be actual
enemies that have to be taken down?
Because I've seen a lot of opinions stating
that the Gorosei are basically glorified Spandams.
That's this guy in case you forgot.
[] The reason Spandam was able to control
some of the governments most powerful agents
was not because he was smart enough to manipulate
them, but because they were ordered by the
government, in other words the gorosei to
help him.
Now you could say that the main source of
authority for the Gorosei is that they have
both the Marines and the CP agencies under
their command.
However how do they keep authority over those
groups?
After all there is no higher power backing
them up.
Of course there is Imu, but people don't know
about her.
If they truly were just Spandams, surely in
the 800 year history of the government, some
Marine or government agent would have tried
to usurp them.
Or even the revolutionary army might have
gone straight for their heads.
Akainu surely wouldn't have listened to them,
if they didn't have anything to back up their
authority.
And yet Sengoku and Akainu never think about
actually going against them.
At least so far.
But I want you to notice just how calm the
Gorosei are at Sakazuki's insolence.
Normally, people would be trembling like Coby
at an angry Sakazuki, but the Gorosei simply
shrugg it off, mocking him and treating him
like a tempered child.
Weaklings don't show this confidence, especially
since these five aren't stupid.
And then they are casually meeting with one
of the most powerful pirates in the entire
world, dismissing their guards.
No matter what powers they have at their disposal,
the fact that they appear to have battle experience
and unwavering authority over people like
Akainu and Lucci proves to me, that they all
must be immensely physically powerful, especially
after they realized that they could subscribe
to my channel for more weekly One Piece content.
The big question I have always asked myself
is 'how evil are these guys'?
Or are they evil at all?
This is a truly interesting question, because
I think that other than doflamingo for example,
the Gorosei are in a much more morally grey
area.
On the one hand they lead a regime that uses
slavery, neglects and manipulates its people
and orders the destruction of an entire island.
But then Oda-sensei still throws in nuances
that make them appear more human.
During the Ohara incident, at least some of
them seem pained with their decision.
They actually wanted Jinbe to create a better
relationship with the fishmen and allowed
them access to the Reverie.
And they clearly were not happy with Doflamingo's
actions, but couldn't do anything about it,
since he was a celestial dragon himself with
knowledge about the national treasure of Marijoe
that he could use as leverage against them.
And they seem to work with Shanks to keep
the world balanced.
This gets even more confusing when looking
at Oda-sensei's inspiration for all five of
them.
What keeps fascinating me every time it think
about it, is that all five of them seem to
be inspired by influential historical political
figures.
Most prominently we have one who looks like
Mahatma Gandhi.
One of them looks like a young Abraham Lincoln,
one like Karl Marx, one like Michael Gorbachov
and the one with the long beard like the Japanese
position Itagaki Taisuke.
Now all of these figures represent very different
political ideologies and all of them had their
flaws, but what unites all of them at least
from a historical perspective was that they
are associated with giving people more freedom.
Lincoln is known for ending slavery in the
US, Gandhi ended British Colonial Rule in
India, Marx' fundamental idea, that was later
strongly misused by multiple regimes, was
the theory of liberty, stating that the freedom
of the people is the most important right,
that should not be exploited and controlled
by those with power and money.
Gorbachov was the last president of the Soviet
Union, who with his ideas of glasnost and
perestroika (openness and restructuring) promoted
democratic thinking and liberty in Eastern
Europe that ultimately led to the collapse
of the Soviet Union.
And finally Itagaki was leader of the Freedom
and People's Rights Movement and involved
with the founding of the first democratic
political party in Japan.
So either Oda-sensei is being very ironic
by basing the authoritarian rulers of the
world on people fighting for freedom.
Or there is something more to this.
To me the main goal of the government seems
to be to keep the balance of the world.
They meet with Shanks, buy weapons from Kaido
and dealt with mother caramel for powerful
orphans.
Clearly they have no interest in getting rid
of the Yonko system, but rather promote it.
There seem to be only two instances where
the government seems to feel threatened.
One was the incident of Ohara, that might
have revealed the true history to the world,
and the other was Imu's frustration with Luffy,
Vivi, Poseidon and Blackbeard.
No kaido, no Big Mom, no Dragon.
However all those 4 seem to have connections
to the void century, except Blackbeard, who
seems to have connections to Rocks, who also
was a major threat to the government.
Luffy's straw hat connects him to the giant
straw hat on Marijoe, Shirahishi is a ancient
weapon and Vivi is connected to Pluton and
the only of the 20 kingdoms, that didn't join
the celestial dragons on the red line.
As for shanks, I don't think he's plotting
with the government, but trying his best to
ease the way for Luffy and keep the world
from falling apart before he has found the
one piece.
So are the Gorosei just interested in keeping
things as they are to keep living in comfort
forever?
They do seem to have a fairly stressful job
though.
I really can't wait to find out what their
connection with Imu is.
I think it would be a very interesting twist
if one of them, either Imu or the Gorosei
was actually a 'good guy' after all, keeping
the other in check.
But let's talk about the immortality thing.
There are actually a number of theories out
there that connect imu and the gorosei to
immortality.
One option being of course the OP OP no mi
that might have been used multiple times.
Another theory is connected to the theme of
flowers.
A golden flower that connected Imu and Nika
and the Lunarians.
I should probably make a separate video just
about that idea.
And the biggest theory with the most evidence
behind it is this video right here, where
I explain all the reasons why imu and the
celestial dragons are immortal and what the
secret behind that might be.
You know, if you're interested.